everybody you've already met but they
don't know that in the video this is
talk about the introduction to Kotlin
multi-platform my name is kevin Galligan
i am a partner at a company called touch
lab and I have a few decades of coding a
couple professionally again on the
Android thing I was doing Android
development before they had a phone so
let's say a decade of that to touch lab
is like a mostly mobile shop and it was
an Android shop for from like 2010 up
until a few years ago and then well we
make kind of apps and weird hardware
things there's a thing called a mirror
where you can like put it on the wall
and there's like workout videos and
yadda that's based on Android there's a
in New York they have a tower where you
can have a touch screen it's replaced
the payphones we worked on that too
anyway I kind of took a detour in my
career a few years ago to basically
focus on this tech multi-platform tech
and someone really do any consulting
company stuff anymore it's all research
and open source and coming to speak at
various things and our first partner in
that worlds actually been pretty great
so this company called square and they
make a lot of open source stuff in the
Android world and they're super into
multi-platform and with them we've
actually been working mostly on making
Kotla multi-platform more appealing to
iOS developers and we have some
interesting stuff from that but we're
having a library talk that two o'clock
or 1400 which we talk a little more
about the library so what is Kotla
multi-platform so in the native mobile
world essentially mobile developers
think of things as you're either doing
the native platform and language or
you're doing everything else which is
cross-platform and that's not a precise
conversation and it's a disservice to
the various pieces of tech out there so
I kind of start by giving the definition
as precise as I can and this is like the
most concise definition of what I think
column multi-platform is at like what
differentiates it from other
technologies so it is optional natively
integrated open source code sharing
platform based on the popular
Modern Language Kotlin that facilitates
non-ui logic available and available on
many platforms right and then this slide
is like a year old and I haven't really
updated so the other big important
differentiator is chip rings so I'll
have to redesign the slide at some point
but I didn't for this talk so anyway
what that means is I'm gonna break this
down optional sharing is a lot of the
technologies the cross-platform stuff
they want you to like build an app
within their technology so react native
is kind of like hey you can build apps
with JavaScript and then you're kind of
in their ecosystem and like flutters the
same thing and zamarons kind of the same
thing it is what we call a big decision
you have to like rewrite a bunch of
stuff or you have to write a bunch of
British logic it's running in its own VM
it's doing a lot of stuff like that and
big decisions are risky and especially I
spend a lot of time talking to Android
developers and I have to sort of remind
people like this I know this text
appealing but the way that orgs think
about things is different than maybe an
individual developer and risk is a much
bigger problem for larger orgs so
optional sharing is very important
natively integrated so call it attempts
to live within the ecosystem that it's
operating so again one of the big
problems with react native is you know
there's a big bridge between the
JavaScript in the native environments
same thing flutter same thing with
xamarin if you want to integrate with
native stuff you gotta bust up the C++
sometimes that's not really gonna fly in
a large-scale environment colonists
attempting to natively integrate which
dovetails well with the optional nature
of the the code sharing so open source
I mean 2019 you couldn't launch a new
coding platform you know realistically
that isn't completely open-source Geoff
Prince is a great job of developing in
the open so even though you don't know
what they're like plans are in the
future you can see what they're
committing and see what's happening yeah
I have a long talk about why this isn't
just Swift for Android but since most of
your arm native mobile developers anyway
we'll skip that part
code sharing and again not
cross-platform
I don't really say cross-platform a lot
except ironically it's just a go term
that is it has a lot of baggage and I
just kind of call like a ruined term if
you can't really say it because it just
brings up you
you know cross platform is PhoneGap in
2012 cross platform is xamarin and we
couldn't figure out the memory problem
cross platform is all these things it's
just not useful code sharing is an
entirely different thing so we that's
kind of always say and popular and I
don't mean popular in a sense that like
hey the cool kids are doing it that's
not why popular is important right this
is a talk I gave at droidcon UK a year
ago way more people showed up than I
thought
someone pointed it out that if it's so
popular why are they all looking at
their phones and I said that's because I
took the photo before I started speaking
but anyway popularity is important
because ecosystems that aren't popular
don't have big communities they don't
have a lot of libraries there's not a
lot of people you can try to hire
there's not a lot of training
opportunity that is the opposite
situation here this is growing in
popularity significantly and very fast
and we're there's already an existing
Android community that's large and very
engaged that is converting over to this
ecosystem it's just an important aspect
that you have to consider when deciding
on technology and modern so I don't mean
like the null ability syntax is like
Swift that's why it's modern I mean that
if you watch the Kotlin comp we know
from last year Jeff rains is proud of
the fact that they're not trying to go
out and do completely new things they're
taking the best practices of building
languages and incorporating them over
time so the language is modern and stays
modern going forward
I am personally very focused on their
concurrency model which is what I'm
talking about at Kotlin comp which is
its own internal kind of battle going on
in the community but at least people are
talking about it and it's kind of
interesting so and not you I and when I
say not you I mean not necessarily you I
definitely people are going to do weird
shared UI things I think in certain
silos there's gonna be a lot of success
if you want a form builder there's going
to be probably 15 form builders in a
couple of years but again a lot of the
cross-platform stuff is trying to do
like one UI everything in one big
package and I don't think that's the
right way to go I think starting from
the bottom up and then sharing UI
optionally or sharing up into the stack
as much as you want
I don't know if this is something you
shouldn't do in a talk but I feel like
quoting yourself in the talk is not a
great idea but I am I so share you I has
like a history of pain and failure but
shared logic is the history of computers
which kind of sums up my thoughts on
these different technology options and
why I think it's not like Kotlin is
gonna succeed or flutter is going to
succeed and the other will fail its
Kotlin is going to be successful as a
shared code option everything else
whatever we'll see but if you're trying
to share everything it's just a risky
thing that doesn't have a good track
record so many platforms and this is a
short diagram of the many platforms
we'll talk about them a little later but
there's a lot of places where you can
put Kotlin and I know that sounds a
little weird but it tends to work fairly
well and we'll see so an ID and tooling
that's why the end jetbrains is
important if you're not a mobile
developer or an Android developer if
you're not like a JVM Java developer you
might not be familiar with IntelliJ or
JetBrains but JetBrains
is I think the best tooling maker in the
market they've been around for decades
and they're making Kotlin and the tools
around it and they're very invested in
it so I think if anybody's gonna be
successful
it's them I was you know into some of
these other alternate jvm languages for
a little while and none of them have
like a major org that's also making the
tooling which is I think critical so
there's a summary by Kotlin high
efficiency low risk modern language
tools highly engaged community that's
that now again I am a native mobile
developer so we will talk a bit about
not native mobile development but that's
essentially what I focus on and yeah you
can output JavaScript with Catlin
multi-platform you can have put web
assembly you know I'm a big into
mechanical keyboards you can probably
like you know write to the the
controller on there with Kotlin but
that's not important what's really
important right now the killer app
another JavaScript important like
slowdown didn't mean that but the killer
app out of the gate is gonna be sharing
native mobile code and mobile is easy
and when I say easy I mean relatively
because under the hood Android and iOS
are essentially like the same thing
they're both UNIX II they both have
files and network
and threads and sequel architecturally
speaking they're very similar ecosystems
so sharing logic and architecture is
very doable and the fact that you can
share some things or a lot of things
means that you can do it in pieces and
you can choose how much you want to do
so if you're doing tax calculations that
are very complex and need to be tested
like crazy like sure you can do that and
you can just expose a library to iOS and
it's not gonna be a big problem right so
in the mobile site at least the first
killer app is gonna be you know it's
gonna be mobile so technically though
great what is it
it is so first of all multi-platform is
is a compile-time construct at runtime
multi-platform doesn't mean anything so
multi-platform is a way to represent
shared code but have it compiled down
and deployed in multiple platforms
specifically and the three main targets
or JVM jeaious and native they all have
again this diagram many specific targets
so in the JVM you're gonna have multiple
versions of Java you can target or
Android specifically which will have all
the Android stuff like even a Bluetooth
or whatever JavaScript again I know less
about Kotlin JavaScript there's sort of
a browser flavor and a server flavor I
know that there's some more work that
needs to be done for typescript to be
fully compatible yadda yadda yadda
they're working on it I don't know much
about it but you can google that then
native I know a whole bunch about native
this is essentially what I do all day
now is make Android code work on the
iPhone but there's a lot of native
targets right so you've got the phone
watch TV in the Apple world Mac OS Linux
Direct Linux targeting windows I haven't
done native Windows in 15 years but you
can do windows there webassembly which
we'll see about the future I expected
more web assembly by now but we'll see
in the next five plus years I'm pretty
excited about it but I don't know it's
taken a while so anyway the three main
targets are JVM jeaious and native and
again I'm mostly gonna kind of focus on
this world from now on in the talk with
some exceptions so let's say you're
going to make a thing and on the native
side
what happens is you have common code
that defines you know essentially the
common logic of what you want to do and
then there's a hierarchy of source sets
that will provide this platform specific
stuff that you need to implement some of
those things so if you're making a
library you could have multiple layers
of code but in reality for making an app
you usually just have common and
whatever the platform is specific thing
is from there it compiles down to let's
say an Xcode framework and then Xcode
could import it and you can talk to that
from Swift or objective-c as if it was
like another framework if you're an iOS
developer yes it is Objective C as an
interface right now they are going to
focus on Swift direct Interop next year
the others ABI stability but Swift has
had to spend several years learning how
to talk to Objective C so there's a lot
of optimizations to make that like not
terrible on the Iowa job sorry the
Android side Android and Kotlin kind of
are like Superfriends now so that works
really well and the one thing that's
really important to people when
evaluating the tech I like to remind
them is you know a lot of other
cross-platform options are
cross-platform on both side for this
Android is 100% native you do exactly
what you would do in a normal situation
so there's no like risk added to the
Android side which is fairly unique in
this world and then this is a good time
to remind you that it's not like hey iOS
developer now you can do your UI kit
stuff in Kotlin it's really not how it
works you can start with just a little
bit so you can share nobody I know in
the iOS world likes core data so you can
share your database logic and then
nothing else or you could share your
analytics calls so they're homogeneous
and nothing else you can share a bunch
of stuff and some of our sample apps you
share everything up to the UI and then
the UI is as dumb as possible so most
apps are gonna look like this where you
just do all your normal things and then
start sharing critical code and testing
it better things like that so what's the
status of this um fun part about
prepping for this talk I got to look at
my predictions from last year and figure
out how wrong I was so since you're not
native mobile developers and a lot of
you aren't super super Kotlin expert
they're just thing called co-routines
and I won't explain what that is but
it's related to concurrency and it's
very important to that world and the
native team did not have multi-threaded
covert eenz which is not necessarily
exciting for people that want
concurrency and there were no compiler
plugins so you couldn't do Co gen you
know in a formal way you had to kind of
work at yourself and I figured both of
those things were going to be q1 of this
year and then others like samples and
libraries production app deployments
yadda yadda yadda here's what we
actually are I was wondering whether or
not we would have multi-threaded code
routines at the end of this year and it
turns out that there was a pull request
not a pull request a branch that went in
to finally like implement that a few
days ago so I've spent the past few days
in the hotel like trying to get a sample
working but that's definitely coming and
that's a big psychological barrier to
talk about in a second
good Pilar plugins jeopardy instead they
rewrite their entire compiler so that's
gonna take a little while but we're
about to see many threading libraries
because there is that block of
multi-threaded code routines that's now
unblocked and it's gonna be endless
threading blog post coming out soon and
increase production adoption my job now
is to go meet with companies that are
evaluating or pushing to production and
that is happening at increasingly larger
scales and will do so even more so next
year improves tooling stability but that
all kind of equates into the but you
know the the the the general concept of
this is turning into a mainstream
technology much more so next year is
this ready and that is the question I
get quite a bit and I would say that
that's more about your team will can you
put this in production and will it just
spontaneously crash no it will run in a
stable manner right you're not gonna
have odd memory leaks randomly like it
is stable at a runtime level are the
docs a little out-of-date our things
need to be cleaned up a bit it's like
the tutorials need to be better like
absolutely it is early adopter phase but
it is going to be leaving early adopter
phase sometime in 2020 so this is
something you want to look at you can do
it now but you should be used to like
poking around open source a bit I can
tell you that for sure so and
10300 routines need to change my slides
I have like two other talks gonna be one
today and then one next week and all of
them need to change because they're sort
of related to that it was sort of a
psychological barrier I think a lot of
teams were like well you don't have Co
routines so this isn't ready well that
psychological barrier is about to get
like unblocked so that is gonna change
but again if you don't know what Co
routines are then that doesn't matter as
much so let's see what does sharing code
actually look like again Kotlin embraces
the native of the native platform so the
interrupt story is really good the first
thing that you will notice when you
start is this thing called expect actual
and it said like a new set of keywords
and kind of a new concept although
somewhat explained to me the last night
that this is a lot like externa and see
but I like I don't know maybe but
there's common in your common code that
top thing you would say I expect this
thing to exist and then your other
source sets you're going to say this is
the actual implementation of that thing
you need to have an actual for every
expect in your in your stack somewhere
if you don't the compiler will complain
the IDE will complain
assuming you configure it correctly this
is where the tooling needs to stabilize
a bit but what that looks like is here
we have expect thou is this the main
thread and it returns a boolean right
that's in your common code in Android
which is on the other layer will have
the implementation of what that looks
like on Android which is you want to
check if the looper is my looper and
then an iOS again in a different source
file it just does what happens in iOS
and in JavaScript
it would just be true because that's how
JavaScript works but I left that off the
slide so you can have different
structures that are expect expect the
actual so you have values functions
which is actually I would argue probably
the most day-to-day useful one classes
and you define what should be in the
class and then implement all the things
objects and not going to talk about this
this is more of a library thing but you
can do annotations as well I just kind
of copy pasted that from one of our
libraries
a class and an object look like this I
copied this directly from IntelliJ his
sample that comes out of it for a class
you define the functions you want to
have the values you want to have in this
case also a constructor which is not
always the case and for objects similar
thing and then in here in the common
code you can write a thing that uses
this even though you don't yet have an
implementation which is going to happen
later on the Android side you do actual
class you have to make sure you
implement everything or it will complain
and fail to compile same thing with the
object and then iOS not a lot different
are these useful implementations they
are absolutely not but in a real example
you're gonna have much more complex
types and a lot more stuff going on so
and there's another thing that I'll
briefly talk about it's called type
alias so if you take a look at this this
is from one of our libraries we're
implementing a shared atomic integer so
here's all the things you can do with
the atomic integer and it has this very
specific method signature because on the
JVM side you can just do this and say my
atomic int is actually Java's atomic
integer and then you're done because it
matches that thing a hundred percent
right which is actually pretty neat
unfortunately on the other side in iOS
you have to do this crazy thing where
you pass in and you have a different
delegate that you're wrapping and
carrying around because the the
signatures don't match 100% and between
Android and iOS or JavaScript or
anything else it's extremely rare that
both sides will match 100% out of the
box so you kind of have this whole
delegate hierarchy you have all this
crap going on yet to carry around and
we're going to talk much more about that
in a few hours so we'll kind of leave
that where it is because that's not an
intro-level talk so I will say after all
that expect actual when you get a hammer
everything looks like a nail so the
tendency when you get a new tool is to
overuse it and expect actual is
definitely one of those things every
developer I know that got into Kotlin
multi platform started doing expect
actual everywhere expecting that that's
what you're supposed to do but the
reality is it's a lot easier to share
code with interfaces so here's an
example from a
library called multi-platform settings
and on Android it's it's shared prefs on
iOS it's nsuserdefaults on javascript
it's whatever persistent thing you do
with the map which I don't remember of
top my head and it's an interface it
used to be expect actual which is
actually quite inflexible we'll talk
about in a second and then you're like
okay this is interface and then we can
use expect actual for the function for
like a factory function then each
platform will give you the
implementation you want and then we did
that for a while and then kind of back
that out and then we wound up with this
and one of our apps let's say as an
example we passed in all the
implementation on app initialization and
they just go into the shared service
registry and wound up with like
essentially just interfaces and no
expect actual at all the reason because
then you can do testing much easier you
can pass in mock objects you can pass
stuff like that and if you do everything
expect actual it's much less flexible so
this is from our we have a droidcon app
sample which I'll talk about briefly a
little later but inside the droidcon app
we have this like big central service
registry that we pass all these you know
interfaces and and various
implementations into so other parts of
the app can pull them out and testing
obviously does it a different way if
that feels like a really cheap
dependency injection implementation good
news so hopefully at this conference
we're gonna finalize plans for
implementing multi-platform coin which
we have sort of a fork and and an early
implementation of so hopefully we'll
have that functioning as well so wish
this luck that we sort that out so again
here's another example of an interface
like we have an analytics API and inside
the app we want to have you know shared
analytics so we have log event the
Android implementation is actually oddly
complicated we have to do a switch on
type here the mock implementation not
super complicated it's actually quite
boring we're just deciding whether or
not we called the log events and on the
swift side this is Swift code and you
just pass this in on app startup and
it's actually super straightforward and
much easier than the Android side which
was interesting on the Swift side the
entire setup at the beginning of the app
in the app
delegate kind of looks like this we're
just passing in the platform specific
implementations for like a reasonably
robust app it's doing a lot of things
that's the droidcon app and then the
other way to shared logic that we use a
lot is function args and if I was
redoing these slides which I made you at
some point I would kind of put function
args and interfaces like in the same
section because they're doing a lot of
this very similar things and they work
very similar ways you essentially in
your share code define a function and
you take that as an argument during an
initialization and then on either side
you just implement that with the lambda
syntax and then Swift like in this case
the application wants to load with seed
data so the way we do that with share
code is we we have this function that
says here's the file here's the type
give me the shared data and on Android
it's in the assets folder an iOS it's in
a bundle and we just passed this in in
the initial initialization of the app so
it's very easy to like reach out and do
you know platform specific stuff one
note about that it is somewhat harder to
test and I mean not unit test cuz
obviously if you're doing unit tests you
don't want to be necessarily pulling you
know files from the devices folder you
want to be mocking it out somewhere but
if you're doing sort of higher level
tests where you want to actually test a
platform specific logic that is
difficult because the way that Kotlin
produces is an exe that gets run and you
need to like actually bootstrap this
with XE test yadda yadda yadda just be
aware that there are things that are
more difficult to test using these
techniques so this is the droidcon app
we the other weird thing that I do is I
kind of run track on new york so we made
I think one of the first multi platform
apps published into the App Store and it
is a conference app and it's been now a
year and a half that we've been working
on this it is desperately overdue for a
refactor which is gonna happen
December especially now with
multi-threaded code routines I tried to
get a version a multi-threaded code
routine branch compiling before this
talk but that's not gonna happen till
next week at least check this out it
is a little a little complex to kind of
follow and again I think we were the
first multi-platform app in the app
server we'll see so uh no expect actual
I would say that you want to kind of
minimize it right so just be aware that
just because there's this new keyword
set that it doesn't go everywhere just
you know don't go through that phase of
your Kotlin multi-platform learning for
example the droidcon apps got nine
functions that are expected to classes
it could probably be less functions than
that we just haven't gotten around to
pulling them out and the classes are
like date classes so it's kind of
convenient to wrap stuff like that
on flip side you know we have a library
we're going to talk about in the next
talk where there's a hundred plus
instances of expect and it just depends
on what you're doing essentially so
getting started I would say the droidcon
app is okay but there's like a lot going
on so if it's the first thing you look
at it's going to be kind of difficult to
follow to be perfectly honest this is
big JetBrains doc that walks you through
what multi-platform is technically and
then a whole bunch of stuff in there but
it also talks about like you know if you
want to build a Linux you know
command-line tool or you wanted you know
it's like a lot of stuff and that you're
probably not necessarily I don't want to
do just be aware that it is it is
complete but there's that's good and bad
one of the issues that we found in the
community right now is that there are a
number of tutorials but they're out of
date very fast because everything moves
very fast and people aren't really
maintaining them so if you want to get
started it can be very difficult we
talked to people that like they started
reading something and then you know the
following day they were still like
trying to get the tools set up they were
still trying to get their configuration
set up the Gradle thing wasn't working
yadda yadda so been on our team has a
series of articles called the five
minutes and the first one is essentially
as long as as long as you install these
tools it should take you about five
minutes to clone and build and see how
shared code works so go check take a
look at that and then there's another
one about how to add a library and we're
doing another one about how to build
libraries hopefully in the near future
that one's longer than five minutes to
be honest and we're maintaining those at
committing at least old Kotlin one for
so as soon as there's a new version of
column we update the the thing so
they're consistently up to date probably
the most important thing to do is go
join the Kotlin slack the jetbrains team
is there a bunch of people are in there
that are very helpful I am there you can
reach out and I'm I will actually help
you directly if you're having questions
it's obviously very important the other
thing we are also doing as an org my
consulting company is essentially
pivoting to try to build our future
around this tech so we're doing a bunch
of stuff and and we've talked to a
number of orgs that are evaluating and
usually what that means is they'll have
someone on their team and assign them
like hey do a hack week for multi
platform and they'll find all these
tutorials that are you know mutually
exclusive and they'll try to do things
like let's take our production apps and
and try to do some shared code in our
production apps even though they're not
iOS developers and one in particular it
was like well I got to Thursday before I
could compile anything and then I wrote
a blog post to our team that was
essentially like hey the texts not ready
and I'm like well maybe you know so what
we're doing is this kit where it's just
a set of prototype repos depending on
the kind of stuff you want to do and you
clone them and then a series of getting
started documents and explaining the
necessary things you need to have
essentially like it's like hey read all
this and get through this part to get it
set up and ignore everything else until
you get to here then you get read all
the other blog post you want but it's
trying to accelerate that evaluation
period so my marketing geniuses have
called this the camp kit which I you
know we'll see how that how long that
name sticks and we have sort of this
space-themed but this is a camping theme
I don't know yada yada this is also
December timeframe so I would say mid
December but go here and sign up and you
can get information about that so the
other thing that you also need to know
if you're going to do this is native has
this new concurrency
model and a lot of people try to get
started and just say well I'll figure
that out when I get there and then just
hope that they don't have to worry about
it and you absolutely do if you don't
learn the basics of it you're gonna have
a real problem right and the basic thing
is that mutable state is one thread and
the immutable state is many threads and
there's this new state of state called
frozen and you can freeze your state and
that's how you can share it there's
actually a function that you call on
state that gets makes it frozen and
we're absolutely not going to talk about
that today because it's way out of scope
but you absolutely need to understand
that or you will not be able to do
anything productive on the native side
javascript doesn't matter because you're
not going to be sharing state with
threads so there are JEP reigns links
they are again complete but they're a
little dense kind of advanced the
actually last one was Kotlikoff last
year the lead of native talked about the
model but again I would go back and
watch that once you understand the
basics to understand the basics I have
this series of blog posts that I have
cleverly named stranger threads which
goes through the basics of that and then
I'm in a few weeks back in Copenhagen to
talk about that state model in far more
detail but it is a critical thing that
you need to understand or do anything
productive with native and that is my
talk you can get more information
get me on Twitter you can get me on the
slack and do whatever you need to do
this is not a u.s. audience but we are
aggressively starting to hire to get
more people who are interested in this
tech we are remote but currently not
remote outside of the US although I am
working on the legal aspects of that
that is it does anybody have questions
yes
okay so the question is well what about
our ex Java on the native side if I
could summarize yes okay that is it's a
multi-faceted answer so is there a port
of rx Java that works in Kotlin native
there is
it's called reactive there's a que in
the name because everyone has to put a K
in a Kotlin name as a developer from
Badu who works on that you can use it it
does work however it does mean that you
would have to swap out you know your rx
code for that code and and buy it to
that ecosystem I think everybody in the
Android world is essentially moving to
co-routines so Rx stuff is probably for
concurrency our accepts probably moving
to flow I don't if you've ever done
anything with it okay so that's
essentially where most the Android world
is a phrase that the Android world that
goes to Android conferences certainly
talks about that I don't know how much
it's actually happening in reality but
JetBrains is pushing that and
multi-threaded cortines as I said like
quite literally caught Linux co-routines
has a branch that has multi-threaded
code teens for native and that's going
to be releasing the next version of
Kotlin so that's where everything is
kind of going what happens after your
shared code and how that like propagates
to your platform specific code is like
right now that on Android it would
probably go into like live data what
happens iOS is a little bit undefined
and I don't have a hundred percent clear
answer are there like many people
talking about it and are there many like
half-baked solutions coming out in the
next few weeks
yeah and then sometime next year I'm
sure it'll be something that everyone
starts using but it is a common topic
but you're definitely not going to be
able to just take our X and directly use
it so that's the question okay
sadly yeah you know flows cool you know
I have missed it because before the
Kotlin multi-platform I did this whole
ecosystem with j2 objc and I actually
got our X Java
- working in j2 objc which was a
complete nightmare but it worked yes
how does debugging happen well if you
remember that slide where we had our
partnership with square I actually wrote
a an Xcode plugin that you can visually
debug Kotlin in Xcode so that's how it
happens the next code I don't know it
works though oh I don't know I have no
idea I mean it's all LOD B base so like
if you have a plug-in that does ellaby
ll DB debugging and Visual Studio then
in theory it should work I know someone
did like the vs code is but I haven't
used it so we have we have competing
pull requests into colonnaded with LOD
v4 matters so at some point that's going
to get merged but it's it's all LD be
based so you know there's probably a way
to do it anybody else know all right
well I'm speaking in a little while
about libraries that one's gonna be
compressed for time because it goes into
far more detail about how to actually do
this stuff but thank you for coming
[Applause]